ma première décision c'est de
transformer la ville comme une ville
pour l'éducation pour la jeunesse donc
du coup je rassemble tous les acteurs
qui concerne cette jeunesse pour mettre
tout les lits service dans cette dans
cet objectif là c'est d'incarner
l'écologie parce que les habitants
savent que c'est un engagement depuis
toujours et qu'en plus de ça cette
écologie elle a tellement de sens
qu'elle nous a permis aujourd'hui de
rassembler toute la gauche autour de
valeurs de gauche mais aussi des valeurs
de l'écologie c'est peut-être que je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas les codes
politiques et que du coup je n'ai pas ce
langage qui est développé par l'ensemble
du politique je suis dans les projets et
donc les personnes sont peut-être pas
habitué à voir ce type de langage il
nous a abandonnés en considérant qu'il
fallait aller en marché à livre vivre un
jeu c'est par une autre vie politique et
je tout le monde le regrette parce que
les gens avaient confiance en cet homme
l'un et ça a été une rupture de contrat